[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online it's okay go with him Haley
Eminem's daughter Haley is all grown up
the now 21 year old college student
attends Michigan State University and
often posts gorgeous shots of herself to
the gram kiss me like you wanna be loved
Shawn Mendes posted a clip of himself
covering Ed Sheeran song kiss me with
Camila Kibeho
and Hoda Kotb shared the adorable first
meeting between her bestie and co-host
Kathie Lee Gifford and her newly adopted
daughter Haley joy she is the love of my
life Dancing with the Stars Pro Peta
Murgatroyd shared the quote joys of
motherhood to Instagram with this breast
pumping selfie ahead of Monday night's
show
joking in the caption my milkshakes do
not bring all the boys to the yard
/ trailer it's fun I'm not gonna lie
meanwhile Mariah Carey and boyfriend
Bryan Tanaka are having a relaxing chic
vacay in Cabo celebrating Mimi's
birthday
aka anniversary the pair shared these
fun snaps to the gram on Monday and
shannen doherty honored her late father
on his birthday posting this sweet
collage to Instagram captioning the pics
in part my hero
my mentor I'm ridiculously lucky to have
had him guiding me teaching me and
loving me he still is
[Music]
you